this is a production of Cornell
University I'm going to tell you a
little bit about the research I've been
doing looking at the stabilization and
degradation dynamics of extracellular
DNA and soils and specifically how those
dynamics are impacted by agricultural
management and habitat type so the first
question you might have is what is
extracellular DNA so extracellular or a
DNA is any DNA strand that's not
contained within itself and in soils as
in other natural environments um e DNA
arises when the DNA inside of a living
cell is either actively secreted or more
commonly a cell will die it will vice
and it's cellular contents will spill
out into the environment and in soils a
DNA is important for a variety of
reasons namely it's an important source
of nitrogen and phosphorus so it's
important for nutrient cycling it's an
important structural and functional
component of bacterial biofilms and it's
a key player in horizontal gene transfer
but for the purposes of this talk we're
really concerned about the potential
that a DNA presents to introduce bias to
our estimates of microbial community
structure so this question has really
risen to the forefront in recent years
due to the increasing accessibility of
high and for those of you who aren't
familiar with this method the basic
workflow is that you take a sample and
extract the total DNA from that sample
which will include both intracellular
and extracellular DNA you can amplify a
gene of interest and then directly
sequence those amplicons and under the
sequencing conditions that we use in the
Buckley lab we expect between tens and
hundreds of thousands of sequences per
sample so that's a lot of information
right and as we analyze that information
one of the key assumptions that we're
making is that every DNA sequence that
we see derives directly from a living
cell so the idea is the cell is present
in the soil it's alive and well you kill
it when you extract its DNA
and then you can draw direct comparisons
between your sequences and the living
cells in the soil but a DNA violates
that key assumption namely because the
cell from which a DNA came might have
been dead for a long time but that a DNA
remains stable and sequence a ball in
the soil and you can't tell those right
so the areas of a DNA research where
there's general consensus is that EDMA
can be stabilized on soil minerals
specifically clays and to some extent
stamp sands and also on soil organic
matter and that a DNA can persist over
long periods of time and that it can
make up a really large portion of the
soil DNA pool generally on the order of
like 20% to 80% so it's not
insubstantial where we lack consensus
however is when we start to ask
questions about the extent to which a
DNA is introducing bias to our estimates
of microbial community so there was a
paper that came out last year where they
took a reagent that targets specifically
extracellular DNA they treated soils
with that reagent to remove a DNA and
then compared the sequences from the
treated soils to the untreated soils and
what they found is that there was a
significant a DNA driven bias in terms
of bacterial richness diversity and
community structure so for microbial
ecologists this is big news and it's bad
news because if that's always true it
means that the work that we've been
doing for years has this unaccounted for
source of bias bad but there was another
paper that came out last year also where
they used a similar technique but a
different reagent so comparing treated
and untreated soils and they found that
regardless of the size of the e DN a
pool so even when it was like 80 percent
there was still no significant EDMA
driven bias so what's a researcher to
think right we have these two really
well-respected labs telling us
completely contradictory information and
so as a way to wade into this
conversation I wanted to test the
hypothesis that the degradation dynamics
of Eady
which will influence a DNA driven bias
um vary across gradients of both
agricultural management and also habitat
type and so to start with I needed soils
from a management gradient and so I
chose to use samples from a long-term
corn trial that's been running in Chazy
New York which is like way up in the
north country and this is a multi-decade
study where they've been applying
factorial combinations of intensive
tillage no-till corn biomass removal and
corn biomass return so this has resulted
in a really clear management gradient
that's accompanied by a really clear
soil organic matter gradient and then
for my habitat gradient I chose to
sample more locally this is monkey run
and right here in Ithaca New York and I
collected samples from agriculture
meadow and forest soils at that site and
so as I was testing this hypothesis
I was also bearing in mind to sort of
follow up questions the first of those
is what is controlling the degradation
and stabilization dynamics of edn and
soils and the second of those was over
what time scale do we expect any EDMA
driven bias to be apparent so to try and
answer these questions I performed a
series of laboratory microcosm
experiments where put some soil into a
microcosm and then I added a synthetic
DNA marker so this is real DNA made of
nucleotides but it was synthesized in a
way that I designed so this marker
contains two different sets of Kaymer
sites that allow me to do two different
types of analysis so the first of those
shown here in green here and here well
white at least is a high-throughput
sequencing appropriate primer site so
it's it uses or it will be targeted by
Universal bacterial sequencing primers
the other primer site that I built into
the synthetic a DNA um where primer
sites they're specific only to this gene
right this is it these are primers that
we don't expect to amplify anything else
in our soils so
my soil in my e DNA I allow my
microcosms to incubate and I
periodically collect sub samples of
those and then from each of those sub
samples I collect total DNA or extract
total DNA and again this total DNA
Wilkin will contain both any DNA that
was natively present in the soil but it
will also contain however much of my
synthetic DNA gene is still present so I
have my total DNA and then taking
advantage of those two different primer
sites I use two different types of
analysis on the same deal the first of
those was an EDM a marker specific
quantitative PCR so this is a technique
that will measure only the synthetic DNA
genes not telling me anything about the
rest of the community the second
technique that I use is high throughput
sequencing the technique I was
describing earlier and this technique is
going to tell me not only about how much
of the synthetic DNA is present but also
about what that looks like in the
context of the larger bacterial
community from the soils let me show you
some reason so starting off with these
are the qpcr data from the management
gradient and we have here on the the
y-axis the amount of a DNA that remains
in the sample and then as we move across
the x-axis we're moving through time the
first thing we note is that between time
zero and day seven so that's a one-week
interval and I want to point out that
this is a log scale on the y-axis so
what we're seeing in that first week is
a two to three order of magnitude
decline in the amount of a DNA marker
that's still present followed by
relative stability across the rest of
the experiment so to better understand
these data I fit them using a nonlinear
least squares modeling approach with a
Weibull type mortality curve so this
type of curve has three parameters it
has a starting value parameter so that's
sort of up here it has a decay rate
parameter and then an asymptote range
and the nature of the model allows us to
compare those parameters between
treatments and I want to stop here and
say that the starting quantity parameter
is the same
across all of our data and all of our
datasets which is by design so we feel
good that that was su result we got
right we wanted to start with the same
amount so we're we're really looking for
differences is in the decay rate term
and in the asymptotes or the
stabilization term and what we see for
our management data is that first off we
were not able to detect many differences
in the decay rate terms between
treatments and I want to sort of drive
home at this point that that two to
three order of magnitude decline in E
DNA in the first week um means that you
know we didn't there was a lot of
degradation that was happening that we
didn't capture sufficiently so it's
really coarse resolution and what that
means is that there might be differences
in decay rate that we just aren't able
to see because of the course of our time
but what we are able to see is a
difference in stabilization between
treatments so we found that
stabilization was significantly
different and greater under no-till
management than it was in our tilled
samples so no-till management is
resulting in greater EDMA stabilization
so the next bit of data I want to show
you is the high-throughput sequencing
data from the same management gradient
right so these are the same tubes of DNA
analyzed in a different way and you
probably noticed that this looks a
little bit different um we're still
looking at the amount of a DNA that's
present on the y-axis and we're moving
through time on the x-axis we're still
seeing a two to three order of magnitude
decline in that first seven days so
that's all consistent but what's really
different about the sequencing data
versus the qPCR data is that with with
the qpcr we were able to detect the e
DNA marker in every sample at every time
whereas with the high throughput
sequencing at time well seven days here
we start to lose the ability to see that
DNA in some of our samples so all these
samples that are sitting right down here
on the the x-axis those are samples
where we were not able to detect a DNA
and the samples where we were able to
detect the e DNA
appear are inching really close to this
horizontal line which represents our
estimated limit of detection for
high-throughput sequencing so
essentially high street food sequencing
is a less sensitive method and so even
early on we start to lose the ability to
detect a t DNA and as a result of this
lack of sensitivity we weren't able to
detect any differences between
treatments at any time which is in sharp
contrast to the qpcr data where we were
able to detect differences between atill
than the no-till students so I want to
sort of pause and really drive home that
point about differences in sensitivity
namely that qPCR is a much more
sensitive method of detection than
high-throughput sequencing and that that
difference in sensitivity is going to
impact our ability to see DNA driven
bias so method sensitivity is going to
matter so I'm going to bring us back
into the data now and to show you the
habitat gradient data plotted and
modeled in the same way as the
management data so again we're seeing a
two to three order of magnitude decline
in the first week followed by relative
stability we're still using that same
model modeling we're looking for
differences in this case we were able to
detect a difference between decay rates
namely in that the decay rate of the
forest soils was significantly different
from and slower than the decay rate of
the meadow soils right so forest has
slower degradation than meadow soils
initially but by the end of the
experiment
it's the meadow soil but has
significantly more or significantly
different and more stabilization than
either the agriculture or the forest
soil so there's this decoupling right
between initial degradation and
stabilization and long-term degradation
and stabilization all right and then
when we look at the sequencing data for
those same tubes we're seeing very
similar things to what we saw with the
management data right we're still able
to detect the e DNA standard at time
zero and all of our samples we're still
seeing a two to three order of magnitude
decline in that football and we're
starting to lose the ability to detect
the e DNA in those samples with our
sequencing method
and again we couldn't detect any
differences between treatments with our
sequencing data so pause there bring it
back to this hypothesis that I was
testing
I was testing whether or not a DNA
degradation dynamics would vary across
gradients of habitat and management and
I thought that was not what I want to do
um so I demonstrated that those do both
impact me DNA degradation dynamics right
so both tillage being part of management
and habitat influence stabilization in
the long term all right
so the follow-up question that I was
asking was what's controlling a DNA
degradation and stabilisation dynamics
and so to try and get at this question
because remember I in the management
training I saw this there was a really
strong soil organic matter gradient that
went along with that management gradient
and so soil organic matter seems like a
really good place to start
right when looking for the underlying
controls so I plotted or I look for a
correlation between soil organic matter
that I'm using percent carbon as a proxy
for with the amount of a DNA that was
still present at one so this is after
that initial precipitous decline and
what we see is that there is a strong
positive correlation between soil carbon
and initial a DNA stabilization and that
this correlation is strongly significant
so that's cool right that tells us that
soil organic matter is playing a role
here but interestingly when we look not
at initial stabilization but rather at
longer term stabilization so by the end
of the experiment that correlation
completely disappears so this again
drives home that point that there is a
decoupling between initial degradation
and stabilization and long term
segregation and stabilization so the
second follow-up questions asking was
over what insight what the first
question was what's controlling those
degradation dynamics and what that
decoupling is telling us is that we're
pretty agreed that DNA is entering the
soil as a DNA something happens and
some portion of that a DNA that enters
the soil might ultimately be stabilized
but we have a lot of questions about how
much of the e DNA gets stabilized over
timescales by what what methods and so
our results suggest that when e DNA
enters the soil one of the controls
between entrance and stabilization is
soil carbon right so it's having an
impact on what kind of proceeds on this
pathway towards stabilization but our
results also tell us that soil carbon
isn't the only thing controlling us
right there are some other processes or
set of processes that are controlling
whether or not the e DNA that enters the
system is ultimately stabilized is over
what timescales do we expect cDNA driven
bias to be a parent so this figure is
for illustrative purposes only but what
we're showing is that if we take the
qpcr data where we were able to detect
the e DNA and all samples at all times
and we overlay that sensitive method
data with the limit of detection of our
less sensitive high-throughput
sequencing which is a more common
technique and in many ways more
informative what we're looking for is
the time that it takes after a DNA
addition for the amount of a DNA to drop
below that high throughput sequencing
limit of detection which you can sort of
think of as a veil line right the DNA
might still be present but once it's
below that limit of detection you can't
see it anymore so it's not impacting
your results and this figure shows us
that with a treatment that has really
slow degradation the time that it takes
between the when the e DNA enters the
system and when it drops below that veil
is going to be longer than in a really
fast degradation treatment where that
that time will be shorter and this is
gonna have implications for like
practical implications for sampling
right if you are doing time course
sampling and you are concerned about
will my results be biased by E DNA these
are gonna be important numbers for you
to think about so let me show you um
the numbers that I got and I
want to point out at this point that I
did this sort of analysis for the
habitat data as well as for the
management data down here but that I
also looked at the impacts of moisture
and temperature which were not data that
I presented today um but across all of
these different treatments we're seeing
a pretty wide range of you can think of
it as sort of the delay between when the
EDA is added and when it disappears the
shortest time that we saw was a day and
a half and that was in a very high
moisture soil so that DNA was pretty
much gone immediately as compared to a
really low temperature treatment four
degrees where we're seeing that that EDA
sticks around above the limit of
detection for nearly two weeks right so
that's a big difference this is telling
us that differential a DNA degradation
has an impact on how much bias we're
seeing our results so the directions
that I think this project should take in
the future are first off to really
explore that relationship between short
and long term DNA degradation right we
saw this decoupling between initial and
long-term and as part of that it's going
to be important for us to understand why
we could see that tillage and habitat
impacted long term stabilization but
that soil organic carbon which seemed
like a really likely culprit wasn't
really driving all the way through the
so what other processes are involved
here aggregation is a neurology is it
some other process or set of processes
and then in addition to answering those
questions it's going to be important for
us to gain better resolution in that
first week after a DNA addition so turns
out that sampling after one week is a
little too coarse right we've missed a
lot of information so we want to address
that right go back and look at what that
data tells us and then finally the
experiments that I did are useful right
we learned from them we feel good about
that but it's also really important to
note that they have their limitations
and one of the main limitations of this
type of experiment is that I'm adding a
whole bunch of a DNA at once and then
I'm watching that same DNA marker too
great right
but in natural systems we see constant
turnover of of DNA of microbial biomass
and so that one-time addition isn't
really representative of what's
happening in reality so how do repeated
DNA additions which are more
representative what happens in reality
how do they impact degradation and
stabilization of E DNA all right so tie
this all together right we had this
controversy how did we add to that and
so the thing is that I can say you know
we might not be able to say whether or
not we have like maybe all is lost maybe
all isn't lost but what we can say
conclusively is that it's highly likely
that gradients of management and habitat
and moisture and temperature will result
in differential EDMA driven bias in our
results right so these gradients matter
additionally we're gonna need to use
caution when we sample with really fine
time point resolution because of that
sort of delay between when Edie and I
enters the system and when it drops
below our detection threshold and then
finally the sensitivity of our detection
method is going to matter so if not this
really cut and drive like we're all
doomed or no we're all fine right
there's some subtlety there and so I'd
like to end by acknowledging my
committee Dan and Joe who has both been
instrumental in helping me organize and
execute these experiments I'd like to
thank the whole Buckley lab for your
humor and your patience and a specific
shout out to Rowley and Sam for their
help with sequence analysis I'd like to
thank Dennis at the statistical
consulting unit and I'd like to thank
and if anyone has any questions I will
gladly take those
[Applause]
what's the steady-state concentration of
DNA in soil xor the e DNA I know that
what you would find in nature nearest
places about parking generally we see
between 20 picograms of several grams
per gram is sort of maximum
I had a question about the sample
preparation can you get rid of a DNA by
just using different preparation can you
sort of subtract cells from segregate
DNA from intracellular DNA the two
studies that I talked about earlier the
first one used a DNA intercalating dye
called DNA that didn't you know remove
the e DNA from the system that's it
hi and then the second study that I
discussed just used a difference right
and so I did you look like obvious
people they looked into the methods like
anything sort of to distract you what
could be different between these two you
know mentos it's just a matter of the
cell it's an extraction it's you know
how they sound where they sample tact is
not much I'm gonna be really which is to
say that my immediate reaction when I
read both of those papers was to start
pointing out flaws in their methods and
I could do that but it seems more
productive to rather than try and like
tear down what people had done you can
sort of add the conversation but some of
the methods that they use specifically
the DNA intercalating guy could be
really powerful but there's also you're
sort of like many many steps away from
nature that way so there are always
flaws in the methods and i think that
you know as research into this a DNA
driven bias increases right like the
more people who read these papers were
happily you know everything's messed up
i think people are gonna really nail
down the best way to address
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu